je fais des mouvements rapides pour
capter votre attention pour la
vingt-troisième vidéo du calendrier de
l'avent et là j'ai une question
qu'est-ce qui comporte 140 plan de
sauvetage pour vous sauver hauteur d'une
minute de 5 minutes ou de dix minutes
mais qui coûtent moins de 3 euros
c'est le cadeau que je vous présente
aujourd'hui ce 23 décembre je fais des
mouvements avec la main pour avoir l'air
plus intéressant je fais mon petit
intéressant aujourd'hui petit jeu pour
tuer le temps de laurent galets qui a
écrit plein plein de livres en new york
a créé plein plein plein plein plein
plein de jeux je sais que ce mec a vendu
plus de deux millions d'exemplaires de
tous les produits qu'il a fait et ça
c'est une vraie réussite
je me suis pas encore beaucoup servi un
jeu les que récemment
je cherchais en fait un vrai livre un
peu rigolo et pas cher pour la dernière
vidéo oui parce que petit spoil
c'est la dernière vidéo où je vous
présente quelque chose demain si vous
venez sur la chaîne je vous le dis
sincèrement je vous propose quelque
chose de ouf issime mais ça c'est demain
c'est à 6h du matin voilà comme ça vous
le savez petit jeu pour tue le temps
comme son nom l'indiqué à l'intérieur il
ya des jeux qui dure une minute des jeux
qui dure cinq minutes des jeux qui dure
10 minutes et des jeux à faire à
plusieurs c'est le concept du lille et
le concept et respecter à 100% du style
je prends un jeu d'une minute pour voir
c'est insultant votre bâillements est-il
communicative arefi l'élan en essayant
de faire bâiller le maximum de personnes
en un minimum de temps donc de personnes
lui auraient et une autre ça à chaque
fois c'est un petit jeu débile un petit
casse tête un petit gribouillages un
petit google
alors oui je suis en train de me dire en
le feuilletant ça me rappelle le livre
de squeeze puisque je les faillites et
le genre il décrit il ya un peu de ça
c'est vrai il ya un point commun avec
les nids de smoothies des jeux donc de
cinq minutes donc là on commence à
attaquer du labyrinthe sérieux on a un
jeu de calcul tous des casse tête un
petit peu plus coriace
les jeux de dix minutes on retrouve
encore les principes des passe temps des
calculs tous et toujours les mêmes je
mets un peu plus complexifiés des jeux
de dix minutes on passe une étape par
exemple et dim
mais vous si vous suivez la chaîne j'ai
déjà posé une unique
comme ça dans les énigmes de 2016
avant-hier l'udc avait 13 ans l'année
prochaine il en aura 16 comment est ce
possible
allez ceux qui savent ne dit pas tout de
suite si vous avez déjà vu ça sur ma
chaîne il ya un an mais je vous repose
la question les autres avant-hier l'udc
avait 13 ans l'année prochaine il en
aura 16 comment est ce possible
le et derrière la caméra est ce que tu
as une idée de comment c'est possible
oui vraiment c'est pas mal parce que tu
m'avais sur la chaîne ou là tu as une
idée une idée
ben je vous laisse chercher ça la
réponse est situé dans son anniversaire
voilà c'est lundi la réponse est situé
dans ce money version et après les jeux
à plusieurs on a soit des petites
batailles navales
soit des idées de jeu avec des règles
simples où tu peux jouer sans rien des
variantes du pendu du ni oui ni non du
le compte est bon dit le mot le plus
long
voilà je trouve que c'est le petit livre
qu'on aime bien
franchement c'est une bonne idée bravo
laurent gaga les jeux tu applaudis avec
mais demain parce qu'avec une seule main
on n'aurait pas le son quant à vous je
vous like si vous voulez faire la même
chose c'est avec plaisir le lien est
dans la description avec le mont lien
pour le spectacle donné un piia juste au
dessus c'est une bonne idée quatre
dernières minutes
je vous invite à vous abonner si c'est
pas encore fait d'être gentil avec vos
proches si c'est pas encore fait et
rendez vous demain pour la dernière
vidéo du mode décembre et l'annoncent de
mon petit bonhomme ça devrait te plaire
vraiment soit leur rendez-vous à 6
heures ciao quand est-ce que cet arrêt
de cette vidéo on ne sait pas je le sais
pas moi même et personne ne sait est ce
qu'on sera un jour je vous êtes encore
stop
[Musique]
oh